[sad music]
Why, hello. I didn't see you there.
GET OUT!!
What are you doing sneaking into a guy's place?!
I'LL CALL THE CO-
Hello again.
Welcome to Channel Awesome's Youtube channel.
Where you can watch me as The Nostalgia Critic.
Reviewing anything and everything relating to your nostalgia.
But it's so much more than watching me as The Nostalgia Critic. (Not really)
You can watch me as Chester A. Bum on Bum Reviews,
Dominic on Video Game Confessions,
And my most challenging character, Doug Walker in various sketches, Vlogs, and review shows.
If you don't like watching my face though, I pity you.
But also recommend a vast variety of other shows that we have.
Including ones that sometimes have my face in it.
So you won't have to panic too much.
Or if you want to check out even more people, you can check out channelawesome.com
Home to some great reviewers and comedic talent that are not me.
But for not being me, they're pretty good.
So search around and find what you enjoy.
All are welcomed here,
especially the elephants that are flying around my face.
What is in this shi-
["Channel Awesome" theme]